The muscle, the most important system in the human body, making up more than half its weight.
Five hundred muscles for putting the skeleton into gear and allowing us to move.
The muscles are told how to move by the nervous system.
The opioid muscle to raise the arm.
See to it.
Transmit the instruction to the muscle fibers.
Get a move on, neurotransmitters.
Nobody, no, that's mine!
Hey!
Nerv impulses swoop and spin towards the muscles that are to be moved.
Muscle to look.
Here, it's a command.
To contract the muscle to raise the arm, right?
Yes, Chief, but how do you always know everything?
It comes from years of experience.
Experience, my foot.
It's true, we do the same thing day in and day out.
Light your arty cells, my friends.
When the muscles are working, they need plenty of oxygen.
That's what makes us so tired.
The arm muscles move.
Yes, we are.
But remember, the body's made up of many other muscles.
The stomach, the intestine, the liver, which we've already visited.
And don't forget the most important, the heart.
All these have muscles which make them mold.
Uh, excuse me, Hemo?
Indeed, even the blood vessel we're in right now is made of muscle.
Hang on a minute.
But why? What's there to feel?
Don't be stupid, they're my biceps, my muscles, can't you see?
Here, you'd better work out with these.
They'll make you into a Superman.
That's so.
What a young show-off.
Bring the bubbles here.
There's a shortage of oxygen at the energy factories.
Six oxygen bubbles.
That should make, uh, 685 kilocalories of energy for the muscles.
Ah, good. The body can keep going as long as it doesn't overdo it.
Like, roly-poly, don't run into the street. Here, you'll get run over.
Just now the pulse rate was 70 beats per minute. Now it's 110. No, 120. What's happening?
Hmm? Seems to be in a great hurry. Look there. Look at that.
See? 180? 190? 200? 210? What?
catastrophe we're nearing the physiological threshold there's a very
real risk of collapse any moment now there won't be enough fuel for the
muscles sound the alarm well that's it nothing left what emergency emergency
message for the command centers there you are speedy there's a shortage of
sugar and what's more an insufficient oxygenation of the muscles here at the
double get this to maestro immediately the heart it's it's making 200 beats a
A minute now. The muscles have finished. What's to be done?
Oh, thanks.
Emergency message from the limbs.
Shortage of sugar, lack of oxygen, grave risk of collapse.
Very well, my friends.
Send a message to the sympathetic system to accelerate the respiration.
And a message to the liver to send sugar reserves.
If necessary, we always have a last resort in the form of fat reserves.
There you are.
There's no need to get worked up.
A young organism is incredibly resilient.
You'll see.
...intercostal muscles to accelerate respiration.
I repeat, all intercostal muscles are ordered to accelerate respiration.
Command to all intercostal muscles.
It's insane.
We have to accelerate the heartbeat, and yet there's still a grave shortage of oxygen.
And what's going on above us, eh?
Hey, what is it?
Have a look at what's been happening whilst you've been sleeping.
Just look at the screen.
It looks as if there's no sugar left.
Well, that's too bad. It's not my job to make more.
Well, if I'm told to bring oxygen, I bring oxygen.
But, of course, if others don't cooperate, then everything's a shambles, isn't it?
Look, there's no more sugar, so are you telling me I can't do my job, huh?
It's not my fault the sugars run out, and you know as well as I do that I can't make the stuff.
If you're so worried about the shambles, why don't you find some sugar, Mr. Small?
You forget I'm an oxygen specialist.
Oh, yes? That doesn't mean you can't help out.
Oh, come on, children. Don't squabble like this.
It's natural for the sugar reserves to run out sometimes.
Excuse me, maestro, but if there's no more sugar to burn, what am I supposed to do to produce more energy?
They're nagging me the whole time for more energy.
Ah, come on, don't get into a state. If there's no sugar left, you could always burn fat.
There's usually plenty of that. I suggest you start tapping the fat reserves.
Not fair. We're the only ones doing any work.
Right. The body won't be able to move.
The heartbeat, the respiration. It's all due to us muscles.
Do you realize, even when they're asleep up there, we have to carry on working?
We've got a really rotten deal.
What's more, we're not being supplied with enough sugar fuel.
Right, just not fair.
If I don't get something in my stomach, I'm going to go on strike.
You should know them by now, they'll find some way to keep us working.
There's another sweat-bearing gland emptying itself.
I'm afraid the body will soon be short of water.
Might be overheating.
Look at the Ruffini corpuscle.
Hello, Ruffini. Feeling the heat.
When the muscles overwork, it's we who suffer.
It's just not fair.
Mobilization of all fat reserves.
Urgent.
Bye.
Thank goodness for the fat reserves.
It's a good thing we're not too skinny.
Halt.
There's been a change of plan.
You need it over there now.
About turn.
We haven't even been home yet.
I'm sorry, the muscles have a severe shortage of sugar.
About turn.
Why does it have to be us every time?
After all, we're not even sugar.
When does a guy have a chance to get a rest?
And hurry up.
That's 500 calories on their way, another 2,000 still to fight.
Right, let's get to work.
That amount should be just right.
Prepare the slicer for cutting the butter.
That's perfect.
It should make over 2,000 calories.
Right, right.
I'm staying at home. I don't like traveling.
You must be mad. I love traveling around, visiting the energy factories. It's fun.
You'd have to pay me to go. I don't like running.
Ah, my friends. I can't keep up at this pace. Not at my age.
No, dear.
This way, please. It's not very far now.
Proceed in the direction of the leg muscles.
Over there. You platelets, come here.
And please calm down.
Down there, we've got some very stubborn lipids,
and your job is to ease the circulation.
All right, get to work now at the double.
You lot.
You'll find the exit straight ahead.
Thanks.
Look at all.
In time, now we can produce more energy.
Exhausted. You don't seem to have any idea how dangerous it is to run in the street.
Peter, what's this? Are you training?
Not really. My dog ran into the street. It's all his fault.
You shouldn't overdo it, you know.
You don't know what overdoing it even means.
Watch out. You're going to get a pot belly, my friend.
Just watch it. You should start taking some exercise.
Whenever I see you, you're lounging around clutching some sort of food in your hand.
Not the sporty type.
No problem.
The more you do, the easier it becomes.
What do you mean?
Hmm?
You just have to train, come with me.
'Kay.
See ol' Fatso in front of us?
Let's give him some of my oxygen, he'll never know the difference.
Smear, you've dropped some oxygen.
Hey!
I saw you knocking my basket, now pick up all the bubbles!
Uh, but you see, sir, uh...
No excuses, pick them all up.
A bit of exercise does one good, even at my age.
Very true, and it builds up muscles, doesn't it, Professor?
Ah, but of course.
Ah, yes.
Doing well. Keep it up.
You were right. I can feel this exercise do me good already.
Hey, Struffy, get a load of that.
Are they showing off or what?
Well, let's show them a thing or two, shall we?
Yes, let's. It's about time we had a bit of sport, eh?
Watch, I'll give you some sport.
Hey, you! What do you think you're trying to prove?
Why did you trip him up?
Something's annoyed him.
I'm going to make you pay for that.
Rather leave it, Jumbo.
These two aren't fit enough.
Anyone can see they wouldn't stand a chance.
You'd better watch what you say.
We're every bit as fit as you.
Want me to show you?
Oh, yeah?
Well, then what sport should we play?
Jogging?
Boxing?
What do you say?
And you?
Then volleyball.
Athletics.
Ah, come on.
Tennis.
Basketball.
That's it.
Good.
Basketball's okay.
All right, then.
Let's go.
See you in half an hour.
And no dirty tricks.
Promise.
I swear to it.
now what have you let us in for this time oh come on foxy i'd never let you down i've always got a
trick up my sleeve haven't i that's right sorry i doubted you right you two are you ready to start
okay we're ready to start aren't we internal and external muscles turn the eye seven degrees to the
right object rising up from the ground process the message for interpretation approaching rapidly
at the edge of the field of the vision to the left avatarless muscles in the new field of vision
For contraction of the arm, which has to be transmitted.
Cerebral cortex, please won't you speak up. I can hardly hear you above all this racket, isn't it?
Chaps are good.
All gone, come on.
What's going on?
What about the messages? Why are they not being passed on?
That accident was your fault. It was purely due to lack of coordination.
Yeah.
Come on, get to work.
Message to perineal muscle, contract.
Message to eyes, move to the left.
Message from the left gluteal muscle.
Chucks being too severely contracted.
Urgent message from the pain center.
Left gluteal muscle's hurting.
Come on, come on. Process this information immediately.
This accident's all your fault.
You have to coordinate everything you see on the screen with the information you receive.
Don't worry, my friend. It's not serious. You'll be all right. You'll see.
Message to the right arm.
Contract the extensor muscle and the triceps at force seven.
Contract the deltoid, force three.
For good ball grip, contract the exterior brachial, the long supinator, the round pronator.
Yes, that's it. Very good. Easy, easy. Force two.
Let's move to the right leg. Let's see the sartorius, then the extensor, the right anterior, force five.
And now to the calf. Contraction, please. Harder, harder. Force seven. Yes, well done. That's good.
Ah, basketball. I remember it well. I used to be quite a star player.
Deltoids and pectorals. Take it gently. Force two to begin with.
Strong contraction of the triceps and of the extensor.
at force eight please that's it and now relax them all very good bravo done it up he's the
one who told us to stop fooling around well cool chief's prerogative ah go this is such fun yes and
i feel wonderfully healthy not at all tired i'd say we're really in good shape listen to me and i'll
go for the redhead well then what are you waiting for i didn't mean to please don't eat me i promise
as I didn't mean to, no, no, no.
You'll be bedridden for a few weeks,
but you're lucky it's not more serious.
Right, I must be off now.
I also have to go, my friend,
but I promise I'll come and visit you again
as soon as I have a free moment, okay?
Okay.
Bring me some more chocolates, right?
Don't you think you should start eating a bit less?
But what else is there to do in bed?
Well, if I were in your place,
I'd be doing some studying.
I'd use the time more constructively.
Would you like me to bring you some books?
You're getting fat, my friend.
You must watch it.
You're so heavy. I don't know why. It's getting harder to move.
I'm also struggling, and I don't know why. It was so easy a while ago.
Hang on. I've suddenly realized what it is that's causing all the trouble.
It's all this fat, that's what.
Am I supposed to do with all this fat, especially when we're having to produce so little energy?
You know what to do?
Okay. About turn. You must go back to the stocks.
We'll call for you only if we need. You understood?
If you break like that, of course I'm going to run into you, idiot.
It's all your stupid fault.
It isn't. It was you who accelerated.
GET BACK TO YOUR VEHICLES! WE'VE ENOUGH PROBLEMS WITHOUT THIS SORT OF THING!
More fat! Stop immediately!
We're destroyed any second now!
Oh! We've been sunk by the enemy!
Oh! Oh! Oh! Oh!
Plumpeting towards the cell wall, we're in danger of becoming another fat cell!
That won't do at all!
Do you realize you're putting a dead weight on your poor spine?
That's the equivalent of carrying a load of 20 kilograms on your shoulders, my dear boy!
Not to mention the heart and the lungs getting exhausted from looking after mountains of fat.
No, no, no, no. This has all got to stop.
You're to start getting some exercise, and from now on you're only to eat grilled meats and salads.
All you need is a bit of courage and willpower. You'll be all right, you'll see.